Jeremy Bentham was a man ahead of his time.
Though not a philosopher, he developed a utilitarian
philosophy based on the doing of good to oneself
and others.
He used it to propose fundamental reforms
to a system that he saw as grossly unjust.
His ideas have reverberated down through the
ages to affect the world that we live in today.
In today’s Biographix, we delve into the
life and teachings of Jeremy Bentham.
A Child Prodigy
Jeremy Bentham was born On February 15th,
1748 in Houndsditch, London.
The Bentham’s were a family of wealth, with
income derived from an extremely successful
pawnbroking enterprise in generations past.
His parents, James and Alice, spent their
time in social and intellectual pursuits.
Young Bentham was a child prodigy, with his
extraordinary abilities becoming evident very
early on.
By the age of three he was reading fluently.
On one occasion, when he had just turned three,
he was walking in the woods with his parents
and some other adults.
He became bored with the adult conversation
and decided to return home.
As the adults were absorbed in their conversation,
they didn’t notice his departure.
When they returned home, the adults found
him sitting at a reading desk, absorbed in
reading a book on the history of England.
Jeremy’s classical studies began at the
age of four.
Among the journals of his father, there exists
a piece of paper with the following on it
. . .
The line pasted herein was written by my son,
Jeremy Bentham, the 4th of December 1753,
at the age of five years, nine months and
nineteen days.
The line in question was a long phrase in
Latin.
This document shows, not only the amazing
talent of the child, but also the obvious
pride that the father had in his son’s intellectual
gifts.
In fact, James, was constantly bragging about
the genius that lay within his boy.
At age four, Jeremy was learning both the
Greek and Latin languages.
James employed a clerk and this man was given
the duty of teaching young James to write
as well as to read music and play the violin.
By the age of six, a regular music tutor had
been employed and James, with his miniature
fiddle, became an adept violinist.
James wanted for his son to excel at everything.
When Jeremy was seven, he was given dancing
lessons.
It was something that he absolutely detested.
The boy was so weak that he was unable to
support himself on his tiptoes.
Yet, his father repeatedly forced him to go
through the exercises, becoming more exasperated
with every failed attempt.
When not absorbed in his studies with his
father, Jeremy loved nothing better than to
spend time at the country estates of his two
grandmothers at Browning Hill and Barking.
He was a lover and nature and would spend
hours exploring the flowers and trees of the
family grounds.
Westminster
While young James was mentally superior to
his peers, physically he was anything about.
He was much shorter than other children of
his age and was extremely thin and weak.
When he was seven years of age, he began attending
Westminster School in London.
He immediately hated the experience, it being
a far contrast to the one on one instruction
he had been receiving almost since birth.
James later wrote . . .
Westminster was a wretched place for instruction.
I was the least boy in the school, and the
bigger boys took pleasure in pitting us one
against another.
Bentham was entered into the upper second
form due to his obvious advanced intellect.
He soon gained a reputation as ‘the little
philosopher’ as a result of his ability
to reason and consider every matter.
His skills in Latin and Greek made him a valuable
boy to know and many of the other boys leaned
on him to provide homework answers.
Bentham soon became a target for bullies at
the school.
However, there was one boy who served as a
protector for him.
If it wasn’t for this companionship, he
would have been the subject of daily humiliations.
In his older years he spoke with disgust at
the fagging system by which the younger boys
were subjected to all manner of intolerant
treatment.
He was just as dismissive of the teaching
that was offered at the school, saying that
he was taught few useful and many useless
things.
Bentham observed the higher the rank of a
professor, the less efficient that man was.
On to Oxford
Bentham persevered with the agony and boredom
of Westminster for five years.
Finally, at age twelve he graduated and his
father enrolled him at Queens College in Oxford.
It was a remarkable achievement for a such
a young man to be enrolled at university.
The fact that Bentham was extremely short
for a twelve-year-old made him an even greater
curiosity than usual and he was stared at
wherever he went.
In addition to developing an extraordinary
intellectual body of knowledge, by the time
he was a teenager, Bentham had also built
for himself a strong moral code.
He recalled . . .
I never told a lie.
I never, in my remembrance, did what I knew
to be a dishonest thing.
His father placed him under the care of a
personal tutor by the name of Jacob Jefferson.
He was a morose and gloomy person who saw
it as his duty to prevent Jeremy from having
anything that resembled fun.
The only thing that remotely approached fun
in Jeremy’s life was to play shuttlecock
very irregularly.
Yet, even this was unacceptable to Jefferson
and he would interrupt the game and usher
the boy back to his books.
He instilled in Bentham’s psyche that any
activity that did involve educational advancement
was a waste of time.
While at Oxford, Bentham received only a modest
allowance from his father.
This meant that he was forced to incur debt,
to his great horror.
His father was also concerned that the boy
was too timid and shy.
On one occasion, while visiting Oxford, James
took his son into the grand hall at Christ
Church.
At the time, the students there were all assembled
for dinner.
James Instructed his son to walk up and down
the aisles and see if he could find any boys
that he knew.
For Jeremy this was a hellish assignment.
With each succeeding step he felt closer to
fainting.
By the time he had finished, he was red with
embarrassment and had no acquaintances to
report.
His father, though, thought this was an excellent
strategy for his son to get noticed.
Further to that goal, he bought a silk gown
for Jeremy, while the other boys wore plain
gowns.
Bentham found the instruction at Oxford almost
as pointless and uninspiring as he had at
Westminster.
He managed, at times, to escape the monotony
of his routine with fishing, which he was
not particularly fond of.
He found no pleasure in the company of any
other student, considering the vast majority
of them to be immature morons.
When he was sixteen, Jeremy’s father took
him on a tour of France.
He was fascinated by the beauty and architecture
of Paris, being especially impressed by the
wonders of the Palace of Versailles.
Shortly thereafter, his father remarried.
Jeremy’s step mother, the former Mrs Abbott,
had a strained relationship with Bentham and
he also spoke of her with a lack of affection.
In 1766, Bentham took his master’s degree
at Oxford, with a major in law.
To celebrate his graduation his father gave
him a gift of twenty pounds.
The following year he left Oxford.
In his own estimation his education at the
college had not benefited him.
One of his father’s ambitions for him had
failed to materialize.
James had intended that Jeremy would use the
opportunities at the college to establish
contacts that he would be able to exploit
upon graduation in order to make his way on
the world.
But the boy had been unable to shake his natural
timidity and didn’t build any meaningful
relationships with people who could help him
in the future.
A New Path
Bentham was admitted to the bar in 1769, though
he never ended up practicing law.
He became greatly disappointed with the English
legal code, which he considered to be overly
cumbersome and complex.
His disillusionment was compounded upon hearing
a series of lectures by the leading legal
authority of the time, Sir William Blackstone.
After listening to Blackstone, he decided
that he would no longer practice law.
Instead he would write about it.
He would spend his energies on critiquing
the existing law and proposing ways that it
could be improved upon.
Bentham took another tour of France with his
father and step-mother in the latter half
of 1769.
In 1770, Bentham started upon his extensive
writing career.
His first published works were two letters
sent to the London Gazetteer when he was twenty-three.
Of one of these letters he later said . . .
It was a portrait of my character and my love
of fairness . . . Lord Mansfield had been
attacked . . . I showed that there was no
evidence for the story.
Bentham spent an inordinate amount of time
perfecting every word that he committed to
paper.
Everything had to be precise.
His early writings often contain the seeds
of the ideas that were fully fleshed out in
his more famous later works.
Taking on the Americans
In July, 1776, the American colonies issued
their declaration of Independence.
The British government did not lower themselves
to issue an official response.
However, a London based pamphleteer was commissioned
to publish a rebuttal.
The man who was charged with writing the piece
was Jeremy Bentham.
However, the response was not published under
Bentham’s name but was the final chapter
of John Lind’s Answer to the Declaration
of Independence.
Bentham was a good friend of Lind and was
living at his house when Lind was commissioned
to the job.
He was delighted to take on the Americans
in print.
He proceeded to pull apart the Declaration,
ruthlessly exposing its weak points.
He sets the tone in his introduction, declaring
. . .
The opinions of the modern Americans on Government,
like those of their good ancestors on witchcraft,
would be too ridiculous to deserve any notice,
if like them too, contemptible and extravagant
as they be, they had not led to the most serious
evils.
Among his many critiques, Bentham ridicules
the idea of all men being created equal, stating
that it gives equal status to the newborn
baby and to the magistrate.
He also claims that the use of Government
to ensure the attainment of life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness is an oxymoron
– as the exercise of any form of government
will alienate at least one of those inalienable
rights.
Bentham dismisses the framers of the Declaration
of Independence as nothing more than a mob
of radicals, worse even than the German Anabaptists.
He concludes with sincere wishes that these
‘ungrateful and rebellious people’ be
forced back into line.
The Panopticon
Having dismissed the Americans, Bentham set
his focus on writing about social and legal
reforms in his beloved England.
One of his pet projects was a design for an
improved prison building called the Panopticon.
The design of the structure allowed every
prisoner in the facility to be able to be
watched by a single guard without them knowing
whether or not they were under observation.
Bentham was well aware that there was no way
that a single watchman could actually keep
an eye on everyone at the same time, but the
fact that prisoners didn’t know if he was
being watched would, according to Bentham,
force him to regulate his own behaviour.
The Panopticon was a circular building with
a watch-house in the
center where a guard could monitor all of
the inmates.
Bentham described the design as ‘a mill
for grinding rogues honest.’
In 1791, Bentham published a book on his Panopticon
plans.
He fully intended for the prison to be built
and even planned to govern the facility himself.
In 1794 he was able to interest the government
of William Pitt in the idea.
He was paid £2000 for his plans.
After a number of frustrating hold ups, Bentham
ended up buying a plot of land on behalf of
the Crown in 1799.
From his perspective, the site was far from
ideal.
When he requested funds go buy more land,
he was told to simply build a smaller prison.
From this he discerned that there was no real
commitment to penal reform on the part of
the government.
When William Pitt resigned from Parliament
in 1801, enthusiasm for the project waned.
Two years later it was shut down completely.
Bentham was crushed by the closing down of
his pet project, stating . . .
They have murdered my best days!
Utilitarianism
Bentham’s political philosophy is summed
up in the concept of utilitarianism.
It is based on the principle that an action
is right only if it promotes happiness and
wrong if it does not promote happiness.
That happiness relates not only to the instigator
of an action but to the rest of society as
well.
Bentham’s answer to the question, what should
a person do? is that a person should do only
that which produces the best consequences.
Bentham was not a professional philosopher.
As a critic and shaper of the law, he believed
that his utilitarian principle should be the
practical guide by which all people, including
the lawmakers in government, made decisions.
His underlying principle was summed up by
his contemporary Joseph Priestly as . . .
The greatest happiness for the greatest number.
His greatest wish was that the lawmakers of
society would use his principle in order to
remake a more equitable and logical legal
framework for society.
He wrote . . .
If anything could be identified as the fundamental
motivation behind the development of Classical
Utilitarianism it would be the desire to see
useless, corrupt laws and social practices
changed.
In determining what was good and what was
bad, Bentham, believed that the pursuit of
pleasure and the avoidance of pain were the
deciding factors.
He held it as a given that pleasure was good
and pain was bad.
The fact that a person is rich or poor, black
or white, male or female, intelligent or dim
witted should, he believed have absolutely
no bearing on their right to enjoy the same
level of pleasure and avoid the same measure
of pain as anyone else.
In the class defined society that was England
at that time, this was a radical notion.
Bentham was never interested in anything unless
it could be practically applied in society.
In order to help people to apply his utilitarian
theory he developed what he called the Hedonic
Calculus.
By using it, propose would be able to balance
out the pleasurable and painful effects of
any proposed action.
The hedonic calculus includes seven factors
which need to be taken into account in relation
to the pleasure or pain produced when considering
a course of action.
These are the intensity, duration, certainty,
remoteness, extent, purity and fecundity or
likelihood that the sensation will be followed
by more of the same.
An example of fecundity that Bentham gave
was smiling at a stranger.
This may make you feel good for a short period
of time.
But it may also cause that stranger to smile
at someone else and this could keep going
on indefinitely, so the sensation would be
repeated many times over.
Purity is the opposite of fecundity.
We might get a temporary feeling of pleasure
by punching someone in the face, but the chances
are high that they will punch us right back,
in which case we will get the opposite sensation.
So, the sensation is not pure, it is quickly
diluted, so to speak.
The Pool of London
In the 1790’s, Bentham became interested
in helping to clean up a notorious area known
as the Pool of London.
This was a stretch that rang alongside the
River Thames from London Bridge down to Limehouse.
It was a center of crime, vice and all sorts
of illegal activity.
A major problem was shipboard theft with merchants
losing half a million pounds of merchandise
each year.
Bentham worked with a Scottish magistrate
by the name of Patrick Colquhoun for a solution
to the problem.
What they came out out with was the Thames
River Bill, which was passed into law in the
year 1800.
It brought into existence the Thames River
Police.
This force, the first police force in England,
was specifically designed to stop theft and
looting from ships.
It was designed to act as a preventive for
crime, which was a new concept at the time.
International Influence
By the 1780’s, Bentham’s writings and
influence had made him an influential world
thinker.
He was in contact with many people of note.
He kept up a lively communication with Scottish
economist Adam Smith in an attempt to bring
about free-floating interest rates.
He was also in communication with the movers
and shakers of the French revolution.
However, when things devolved into the mass
terror of wholesale beheadings, he roundly
criticized what was happening there.
Animal Rights Advocate
Bentham is remembered as one of the earliest
advocates of animal rights.
Extending his utilitarian philosophy, he stated
that it was not the ability to reason, but
rather the ability to feel which determined
who or what was covered by the pleasure and
pain principle.
Bentham did believe that animals could be
killed for food or if a person was defending
themselves or others from attack, but only
so long as there was no gratuitous suffering
involved.
Bentham was also well ahead of his time when
it came to the issue of women’s rights.
In fact, he once stated that it was the inequality
in the treatment of women that he observed
in his youth that first prompted him to take
on the role of life-long reformer.
Even though he was of the belief that women
were both physically and intellectually weaker
than men, his utilitarian philosophy prescribed
that they should be able to enjoy equal rights.
The Auto Icon
As he approached his eighties, Bentham began
to give serious consideration to his death
and legacy.
He wrote detailed directions regarding what
was to be done with his corpse.
In 1830, he wrote a paper in which he instructed
to the English physician Thomas Southward
Smith to create what he called an auto-icon
and this was attached to his will.
Jeremy Bentham died on June 6th, 1832 at his
home in Westminster, London.
According to his instructions, his body was
dissected in the presence of his friends.
The auto icon was created by reconstructing
the skeleton, replacing the head with a wax
model, and then dressed up in his clothes
and placed on a seat in a glass case.
This effigy, along with the mummified head
of Bentham is still on display at the University
College in London.